[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARCUS COLLINS: So my
name is Marcus Collins
and I am beyond excited
to be with you guys.
Just a little bit
more about me, I'm
a professor at the Ross
School of Business.
I teach in the
marketing department.
Go Blue, absolutely.
We are a warm
audience right now.
But that's actually
the side gig.
The full gig is I work in
advertising in an agency called
Doner based in Southfield.
Even though I work
in advertising,
I'm not necessarily an
advertiser, by trade at least.
I was an engineer
undergrad then I
ended up leaving
engineering because it
wasn't that fun for me--
no offense to an
engineers in the room--
then went to the music
business before I realized
the music industry sucks.
So I came back school
to figure it all out,
and then went out
to go work at Apple,
then went to New York
to work with Beyoncé,
then to the
advertising industry.
And right now, the
space I work in,
is this notion of
customer connections.
That is understanding the
evolving media landscape,
that is the technology
that we uses
sheds data about ourselves--
which you guys know very, very
well, obviously.
Understanding the
behavioral sciences,
that is, the
causality based theory
that guides the behavior
that we take on,
and lastly having a very
close proximity to culture.
Now I've thought about
coming to visit you guys
and speaking to you today, it's
like what do you tell Google?
What do you talk about
with the folks at Google?
And I figured I'd talk
to you about a very
simple concrete concept--
perspective.
Now I love perspective, because
we talked about it a lot.
And we all have one.
But really, it kind of
boils down to this for me--
that things aren't
the way they are,
things are the way that we are.
That is, the way we see
the world often informs
how we behave in the world.
The lenses that we have
by which you see the world
influences the behaviors
that we take on.
And the beautiful
part about this
is that we could look
at the exact same thing
from two totally perspectives
and see two totally
different things.
Here's a way to
tangibilize this.
Take for instance my daughter
Georgia, who I love dearly.
All right, because
she's the best.
Even when she's like
this, I love her dearly.
So Georgia.
Georgia is a fish, right?
She loves to swim.
And I take full
credit for this--
my wife's over
there by the way--
I take full credit for this
because when she was an infant,
we took her to the pool
and I did one of these.
Now, just check it.
So there she goes.
I release.
She gets some air time.
Check it out.
I catch her.
Boom.
A perfect dad.
Perfect five, right?
Now, here's how I saw it.
This was my perspective
as I saw that.
I threw Georgia in the
air, just a little bit.
Nothing alarming,
just a little bit.
Georgia, maybe she saw
it a little bit higher.
My wife?
Marcus!
You're killing our child.
It's all a matter
of perspective.
The way you see the
world also informs
how you behave in the world.
Now I want to talk to
you about perspective,
particularly about culture.
Now culture is one of those
words that we use often.
We talk about it.
We think about it in
media, celebrities,
like that's culture.
Or if you're
company, you say, we
have a foosball
table in the office.
We have a great culture here.
We absorb summer Fridays.
We have a great culture.
But those things are
byproducts of culture.
Culture, I think about
it from the perspective
of anthropology.
Anthropologists describe
culture based on four things.
They are other
beliefs that we hold.
They are the
artifacts that we don,
the rituals, the social
norms that we adhere to,
and the language that we use,
the lexicon, the dialect.
And when these four
things are adopted
among the populace
of people, it's
said to represent their culture.
Right?
And it manifests in
tons of different ways.
It manifests in
their nationality,
in their ethnicity, definitely
the religion they subscribe to,
and, oftentimes, the passion
points that they hold dear.
Right?
And we use iconography
to describe
and to project the
cultures that we
are a part of, the cultures
that we've ascribed to.
Much like a peacock
spreads his wings to mate,
we do the exact same thing
when it comes to the brands
that we hold dear.
Now, look, you guys are smart,
obviously, so you're like,
look, this is totally obvious.
But the obvious
usually isn't obvious
until someone points
it out to you.
For instance, say someone's
going to get some headphones.
I'm going to get
some headphones.
I go into Target.
There's a long line
ahead of headphones.
All the headphones
look the same.
They all kind of have
the same sort of shape.
Which one are people
most likely to buy?
AUDIENCE: Beats.
MARCUS COLLINS: Beats.
Right?
I just met you, but
we know that right?
Beats.
Now, we know this because
Beats is the silhouette
of young America, right?
People don't need to listen
to music using Beats,
it's just an artifact that
we wear around our neck
to say this is who I
am, these are a cultures
that I subscribe to.
Now, are the Beats
better than Bose?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARCUS COLLINS:
Yes, you think so.
Someone's a die hard
Beats fan out there.
I would argue no.
Is Beats better than JBL?
They're my clients.
I definitely say no.
Right?
In fact, a couple of years ago,
someone dissected apart Beats
by Dre headphones
about found it only
takes $17 to make a
Beats by Dre headphones.
When people see that,
they're, like, excuse me,
what did you say?
Yes.
It's no wonder then why
they dominate the market.
It's not because of the value
propositions of the products.
It's because of the brand's
proximity to culture.
Because culture sidesteps
all the conventional wisdoms
that we know of or think about
when we think about marketing.
It's more powerful than
my razor's sharper,
my battery lasts longer,
my car goes faster,
my shampoo has more body, my
deodorant gets you laid, right?
It's more powerful than all
those things, because culture
is associated with
your identity,
the way we see ourselves
and how we want to be seen.
And as Biggie once said, "If
you don't know, now you know."
How about this?
Look, what are these?
AUDIENCE: Loutoutins.
MARCUS COLLINS: Christian
Louboutins, right?
What else are they called?
AUDIENCE: Red bottoms.
MARCUS COLLINS: Red bottoms.
What else are they called?
AUDIENCE: Bloody shoes.
MARCUS COLLINS:
Bloody shoes, yeah.
Look at that.
Yes.
Bloody shoes.
And we know that because
of Ms. Cardi B. Right?
Ms. Cardi B introduced that
language to us in our record
"Bodak Yellow," right?
Which went number
one on Billboard.
Like killed, it murdered
on Billboard, right?
Not only did it
murder on Billboard,
when Cardi B with number
one with "Bodak Yellow,"
she also saw to 217% increase
in search traffic for Christian
Louboutins, which was
equated to about $4.5 million
of media value.
The culture drives commerce.
And if you don't
know, now you know.
Do you guys know this is?
AUDIENCE: Jordan.
MARCUS COLLINS:
Jordan, right, it's OK?
You should stop yourself, yes.
It's Jordan, brand Jordan.
But what else is it called?
AUDIENCE: Jumpman.
MARCUS COLLINS:
Jumpman, right, Jumpman.
And in 2016, who
jumped over Jumpman?
AUDIENCE: Yeezy.
MARCUS COLLINS: Yeah.
My man's way in to culture,
back here by the way.
Yeezy jumped over Jumpman.
Now for those of
you who don't know,
let me translate this for you.
Adidas went from being number
three in shoe manufacturers,
sneaker manufacturer,
in the country and over
to brand Jordan in 2012,
coming in at number two.
And a lot of this was
attributed to what
they called the Yeezy effect.
Kanye made the Yeezys and
just dominated things.
This was also a tribute to
Farrel and Stan Smith, right?
And it just actually Q12,
Adidas overtook Nike.
It was in Q12 sales.
This isn't the first
time we've seen this.
We also saw it with Run DMC.
The impact on culture
drives commerce.
You guys know this guy, right?
Of course, you know this guy.
The most emo rapper ever.
Now I love Drake, he's the best.
The best.
Talks to my soul.
Right?
And you can't go anywhere
without hearing a Drake record.
Drake is the guy.
And we know that Drake
is very closely connected
to his beloved city of Toronto.
And just recently,
in fact, someone
equated the value of Drake on
the economic power of Toronto
that Drake's responsible for
5% of the economy in Toronto,
because there's
the 6 Barber Shop.
There's the 6ix Restaurant.
There's a 6ix nail salon.
All of this language that
was introduced by Drake.
That is ridiculously
powerful, unreal powerful.
This is what culture does.
This is the impact of culture--
the beliefs that we
hold, the artifacts
that we don, the
behaviors we take on,
and the language that we use.
This is culture
with a capital C.
This isn't just hip hop culture.
Though, I can argue
that American culture
is hip hop culture.
Like the ethos of hip hop is I
came from nothing to something,
and now I'm stunting on you.
That's exactly what
American culture is.
I pull myself up by bootstraps
now I'm stunting on you, right?
Which it's no wonder why hip
hop music is the number one
most listened to
genre in the country.
When we talk about culture, we
mean culture with a capital C.
For instance, go back
to 2008, in the middle
of financial crisis 2008.
And you had an
uprising of people
who felt like capitalism
was a very, very bad thing.
So much so that they wanted
to be counterculture.
We're going to be
completely antithetical
to the capitalistic
culture that we lived in.
And we call these people
affectionately hipsters.
Hipster was all about
pushing against what
we know of capitalism,
we know of adorning
ourselves with material.
So we can express
ourselves freely.
They donned artifacts
that were irreverent.
They were ironic in some cases.
You guys bought cars.
They bought ridiculous bikes
and the whole nine, Right?
Grew facial hair,
the whole nine.
What was the drink of
choice for hipsters?
Adult beverage drink of choice?
AUDIENCE: PBR.
MARCUS COLLINS: PBR.
PBR, right?
Now, why PBR?
Because PBR as a brand is
all about egalitarianism.
They're all about
individual expression.
The ethos of the
brand was completely
connected to what the hipster
community, the hipster culture,
was all about.
They found a uniting force
based on the conviction
that they both shared.
And everyone who considered
themselves a hipster
were drinking PBR.
Now, you can look at
that and say, wow,
that's pretty interesting.
But the impact of PBR's
business was through the roof.
Hockey stick growth at the time
with the rising of this culture
that we all call hipsters.
So much so, it turned PBR into
a billion dollar business,
which is ridiculous.
And you can say
that, like, well,
what was the rest
of the market doing?
Well, I'll tell you with
rest of market was doing.
Everyone else was either
declining or flat lining.
Well, PBR was murdering.
If you don't know, now you know
We also know this when
we think about proposing.
Right?
We propose with a diamond.
And why would we
propose with a diamond?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Why would we propose with
a diamond, question mark?
AUDIENCE: Diamonds last forever.
MARCUS COLLINS:
Diamonds last forever.
And who told us that?
AUDIENCE: De Beers.
MARCUS COLLINS: De Beers, yes.
De Beers said
diamonds are forever.
So if you love her or
you love your loved one,
you better get a diamond.
And you know you better
not propose with a ruby,
she's like, you'd better get up.
Try again.
Propose with a diamond
because diamonds last forever,
because diamonds are forever.
So much so that as much love
as you have for that person,
save up three months
of your salary
to show the love within this
rock that lasts forever.
Well, I'll tell you
why De Beers tells you
that it lasts forever, because
the resale value for a diamond
is actually pretty awful.
And they have a monopoly, a
seemingly monopoly, on diamonds
so they constrict the supply
and tell you it lasts forever.
Don't go and resell it, because
you'll see that this is bogus.
And as a result,
when this campaign
hit the market in the
1930s, you started
to propose with a diamond.
And we see the exact same
thing happen in Japan.
They rolled out
the same campaign.
Brands have an impact on culture
end up impacting commerce.
And if you don't
know, now you know.
We also see this when
you think about smiles.
You ever wonder why
back in the day,
people were mean
mothers in their photos,
in their portraits.
And then today, we
can't stop smiling.
We're all smiles, right?
Even Kanya has some
issues with this.
Right?
Now one would says,
well, that's because back
in the day, people's
photos, those pictures
were taken via portrait.
And it took a long time.
And you can't hold
a smile that long.
Like their face gets fatigued,
muscles get fatigued.
And people just kind of
straight looked the whole time.
But even with the
advent of cameras,
people still took very grim,
grimace looking, photos.
And this wasn't because
of the technology.
This is because of the culture.
The belief that the time
was that the idea of smiling
in photos or in portraits
was childlike, was halfwit,
You were last than.
That was the belief.
Which is why the photo of a
standing president, the dude
looks like he belongs in
"The Conjuring" or something.
Completely,
completely not happy.
No joy happening there.
And even at the turn of the
century where cameras became
much more ubiquitous and more
people had access to them,
we still didn't smile
very much in photos.
So if you are a
camera company that
makes your business from people
buying cameras and buying
film and taking lots
and lots of pictures,
people think of taking
photos as a serious business,
they're not taking
a lot of photos,
it's a bad situation for you.
So Eastman Kodak say, we
got to change this up, man.
We have to reposition how
people think about what
photos are meant to be.
So they introduced the
idea of the Kodak moment.
Taking photos is about
capturing, preserving,
these joyous moments.
It's about preserving
these moments that we
have with people that we love.
So much so that we say, cheese,
when we smile and take photos.
Completely changed not only
the belief, but the behavior.
And fortunately,
when this rolled out
at the turn of the century,
it measured very closely,
or lined up very closely,
with a study that
was done on year book photos.
Well it took yearbook
photos over a century's time
and measured the curvature
of faces in the photos
to see how often or how
much people were smiling.
And we saw more and
more were smiling.
This is what we do.
Which is why that guy now
looks like a this kind of guy.
And the results of it was
massive for Kodak's business.
Almost $6 billion dollars.
Kodak closed in 2005.
Unfortunately, they
missed a cultural shift,
kind of play themselves.
WE know how that can end up.
Right?
Not so good, right?
So why does this matter?
Why does any of this matter?
I'll tell you why it matters.
It matters because
brands who lead culture
are more successful
than those who follow.
That is brands who
push culture forward,
brands who contribute to the
culture, are more successful
those who follow.
They contribute to the
beliefs, the artifacts
we don, the language we take
on, the behaviors we take on.
The brands who lead
that push it forward.
And people use those brands
to communicate something
about themselves.
Whether it's Apple, Nike,
Whole Foods, Starbucks,
people are getting tattoos of
Harley Davidson on their body.
You don't seen
anyone walking around
with [INAUDIBLE]
tattooed on their body.
Right?
We use these brands to
communicate our identity.
And when we understand the
impact of culture on commerce,
we can then superimpose it with
what we know of human behavior,
then superimpose that on what
we know of people's behavior
based on the shedding of data
from behaviors we take on
and allow us to better
connect with consumers.
We know who they really are.
Here's a few examples
of this in action.
So Netflix is one of
our clients at Doner.
And Netflix came to
us and said, hey,
you want to launch into
Season 5 of "House of Cards."
It's got a lot of
momentum happening.
Things are going well.
But listen, this
is in the middle
of the most divisive
drama-filled election
cycle we've probably ever
seen, at least in our lifetime.
So how might we be a part
of this cultural movement?
How might we be a part
of the conversation?
So we took on the assignment.
And we said, well, what
cultural thing can we lean into?
What could we take advantage of?
And the first thing
we thought about
was, well, the actual
logo of the show--
upside down flag.
And what does an upside
down flag signaling?
AUDIENCE: Distress.
MARCUS COLLINS: Distress.
Exactly, right?
Culturally, we know
that an upside down flag
means trouble's a-brewing.
Help.
So we thought what more
opportune time then
to launch the teaser for the
Season 5 "House of Cards"
new season than here.
So during the inauguration
of now President Trump,
we launched this little diddy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
MARCUS COLLINS: So
zero media behind it--
which I know is not a
good thing for you guys--
but zero media behind it.
We saw 100,000 shares
per hour for the first 18
hours of launching this thing.
Not because it was so radical,
but because it had a place.
It contributed to the
culture, which allowed people
to communicate how they feel,
which is ridiculously powerful.
Now you can look at
"House of Cards,"
and say, well, that's
already culturally relevant.
That's a cheat,
that's a cheat code.
There's something that's
not as culturally relevant.
Potbelly.
You guys know Potbelly, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARCUS COLLINS: You
guys know Potbelly, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARCUS COLLINS: Ah, good.
I appreciate that.
Great.
So Potbelly, for those who
don't know, who didn't say yes.
Potbelly is a sandwich shop.
They sell sandwiches.
They sell toasted
sandwiches, hand
dipped milkshakes, and
daily baked cookies, TM.
Right?
So that's Potbelly.
Now Potbelly came
to us and said we
want to tell better
stories about the brand.
We want to move from being
this kind of like culty
kind of iconic brand
or culty kind of brand
to an iconic brand,
bring more people in.
So the first thing we
asked them was like, well,
what do you believe?
Why do you exist?
What's the North
Star that guides you?
They said, well, you know, we
believe in fresh ingredients.
We believe in
tastier sandwiches.
Like no, no, no, no.
That's what you do.
Why do you do it?
What's the belief?
Very Simon Sinek
kind of approach.
They said, well, you
know, they don't know.
Had to spend some
time with the CEOs,
spend some time
with the founder.
Founder said, basically,
I make these sandwiches
to make people happy.
And making people happy
making these sandwiches,
that made me happy.
So there's happiness abound.
So we said, well, there is then.
You're not in the business
of making sandwiches,
you're in the
business of happiness.
We need to shift
your perspective,
the way you see the
world, from being
in the sandwich business
to being in the happiness
business.
So we took their communications.
Turned if from being good food,
good vibes, to feed your smile.
Right?
We don't just feed your
bellies, we feed your smiles.
We're all about happiness.
So the question now became
so who do we go after?
Who do we target?
Well, these guys don't
have a lot of money.
They just don't.
Whatever currency I have
in my pocket right now
is probably more than in
their marketing budget.
They have about $20.
Not a lot of money.
So we thought, well, let's
start with the people who
love you most, the people
who are part of your email
distribution.
They are the most ravenous fans.
They love the brand.
Who are those people?
And fortunately for us,
they had a list them.
They called them
the Sandwich Board.
These are the people
they send rebates to.
They test products with them.
Like this is like their people.
So we said give us
those email addresses.
And we took those
email addresses.
And we converted into the
associating Twitter handles.
And the idea was
let's find out who
these people are beyond
being hardcore sandwich fans.
So with Crimson Hexagon, which
is an AI consumer insight
platform, we built this
prototype, a networking mapping
tool, that allowed us to
take those email addresses
or as Twitter handles,
dump them into the tool
and see what these
people have in common.
So this is a rendering of it.
So we take these
Twitter handles,
dump them into the tool.
And we start seeing the
connectivity between them.
The clusters that you
see are conversations,
not about sandwiches,
but about things
that are happening
in their life,
they're happening in culture
and things of that nature,
to get a better understanding
of who these people are.
And in doing this exercise,
we saw four things.
Four things that
were disproportionate
to these people versus
the rest of Twitter.
And here they are.
First, they were
hardcore sports fans.
And truthfully, we
didn't feel like that
was very discriminating,
because like a lot of people
like sports.
It's like, ah, we don't
know if we have any right
to be a part of that.
Then we saw Christians.
And these were like hardcore,
like Joel Osteen happy
Christians.
Which is great, because
it's a happy brand.
But the client, I didn't
want to get into that.
So we kept it moving.
We saw some tech startup,
some MarTech in particular.
But we didn't feel like
what we had any right
to be a part of that.
But then we saw people
talk about music.
Now again, music is not
very discriminating.
Everyone likes music.
I've never met someone in
life who said I hate music.
If you meet that person,
they're monsters, stay away.
Everyone likes music.
So it's not very
discriminating on the surface.
But when we looked closer to
the things are being shared,
we saw there sharing
SoundCloud files, which
is really small in comparison
to Spotify or YouTube or YouTube
or YouTube.
I know where I am.
Very, very small.
So that was actually
very discriminating.
And particularly
SoundCloud, these
aren't usually signed artists.
They're underground artists.
This is a way to
discover new artists.
So we felt that music is
probably a good avenue for us
to get into the
culture, particularly
because we have live musicians
who play during lunch.
So now we got a way in.
So we came up with some
ideas for the client.
And we pitched the ideas.
They said we love
that, that, that, that
and give me some of that.
And the idea was, like,
let's go test some stuff.
Now usually, you get a
focus group of people
to look at the work,
and say, I like that.
And I'll buy that
because I like that work.
Well, typically
they're all lying,
because self-reported
data is terribly flawed,
at least biased.
So instead of asking people,
because we didn't have money
to get it wrong, we decided
to ask their bodies.
So we partnered with Michigan
State's Media Advertising
Psychology Lab and we brought in
respondents to look at the work
that we were proposing in a
full Facebook-like environment.
So they saw some regular
content and then the work
that we were proposing.
So regular content and the
work that we were proposing.
And all of these respondents
were then tracking or taking
their physiological response.
Sweat gland release,
heart cardio activity,
respiratory activity,
eye tracking,
zygomatic muscle, which
is the smile muscle.
And we were attributing
what we knew
of the psychological drivers
to those physiological
manifestations.
And the work that
performed the best, that's
what we put in the market.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Making great
sandwiches that make
people really, really happy.
It's Potbelly's mission.
But how do you own that
position in the social sphere
when your annual revenue is
less than your competitor's ad
budget?
We melted data, tech,
and genuine happiness
to feed smiles across the web.
First, we set our sights on
arguably the most unhappy place
ever, Twitter.
Through our partnership with
Crimson Hexagon, an AI powered
consumer insights platform, we
identified a hundred sad tweets
and had Potbelly
musicians respond
with 100 original happy
songs in real time
all during one lunch day.
- Turn that frown upside down.
- When we learned
Paula's fish died,
we entertained her with this.
- (SINGING) I'm so sorry
to hear about your fish.
- @megmoles fell out of a tree.
- (SINGING) Yeah,
you're tweeting today.
I'm glad you're OK.
- No matter the problem,
we had a happy response.
- (SINGING) I'm just going to
tell you you're the very best.
- We flooded Twitter
with smile songs.
And Twitter-- well,
they smiled back.
But the good vibes
didn't end there.
We helped entire cities
in need of happiness
by creating the smile scale.
A one-of-a-kind algorithm that
synthesizes everything from
weather and traffic data to
results from major sporting
events and social media
happenings across key cities,
then automatically serves
customized pieces of content.
If it's raining in
Dallas, they get this.
If traffic is bad in
Chicago, they see this.
And if Detroit's favorite
baseball team loses,
we cheer them up with this.
The results?
10 times more brand engagements,
20 times more Twitter
followers.
Overall, we spread happiness
to more than 16 million people.
That's a whole lot of smiles.
[END PLAYBACK]
MARCUS COLLINS: The more
important part of this
is that with only $60,000
and the media spin,
we saw 2.8% increase in
store traffic for the stores
where we did smile scale
activations, which is
ridiculously powerful, right?
It was crazy, crazy powerful.
Taking what we know
of available sciences,
applying them to what we
know the evolving landscape
and finding a
vehicle, an access,
license to be a part of culture.
Now, Netflix, kind of sexy,
Potbelly, not so much,
but sort of fun.
Let's get really
brass tacks like CPG,
like this is not
sexy by any stretch.
Let's talk Farmland.
You guys know Farmland?
AUDIENCE: Chicken and stuff?
MARCUS COLLINS: So Farmland,
they're a pork manufacturer.
They sale bacon,
awesome, delicious bacon.
Now you look at a pork
manufacturer like Farmland,
you say, well, there's
nothing cool about Farmland.
So if you saw Farmland
and Supreme together,
they have no
interaction whatsoever.
A high piece like Supreme
and a pork manufacturer
like Farmland, like
we don't know about,
what would they have in common?
Probably like I don't know.
So the question becomes,
then, what do you do?
Or what could be done?
Typically nothing until a brand
likes Supreme jacks your logo.
So Supreme, notorious for
taking other people's IP
and conquesting
it for their own,
they took the logo
of our clients.
And we saw this, like
what are they doing.
This is illegal,
you can't do this.
But Supreme felt like
they can, because they're
going to do whatever
they're going to do.
And in those cases,
you have three choices.
You can either litigate.
That is, you give them
a cease and desist.
You could just ignore it,
which is what most people do,
because Supreme doesn't care.
Or a third, you can join in.
That's what we decided to do.
I'll let the guys from
StockX explain it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- If imitation is the
highest form of flattery,
then Supreme is truly
a world class kiss ass.
The legendary streetwear
company has a long history
of borrowing designs
from other brands.
And last week, they added
another instant classic
to their legacy.
The Week 1 Horizon hats
dropped without much fanfare
despite bearing a striking
resemblance to the Farmland
Foods logo, a Missouri
based pork producer,
probably be least
HYPEBEAST company on Earth.
That was until Friday when
the agro business giant
took to Twitter and called out
the apparent forgery causing
Horizon Hat prices
to immediately pop.
The hats went from $70 before
the tweet to as much as $100
after, a 40% increase overnight.
Proving once again
that streetwear
loves a scandal and controversy
is the cousin of hype.
Turning now to the weekend.
[END PLAYBACK]
So we saw them jack our logo
and we responded in a tweet.
And I guess, somewhat
surprisingly, Twitter
went crazy.
They were like yo.
Lots of energy.
Lots of excitement.
But we didn't stop there.
Because we knew
that Supreme's going
to do another drop
the following week,
we decided to do our own drop.
That is, Farmland opened
up an Instagram handle.
And we created a look book
where we donned our farmers
in Instagram.
So our farmers are
out there doing
what they do and, decked
out in Supreme gear.
Or as the trades would say,
we out-Supremed Supreme.
This got picked up in "Culture,"
got picked up in the trades.
It got picked up in HYPEBEAST.
Just amazing, amazing stuff.
This is considered one of the
best creative activations that
was done in the
last couple months.
But this is really
where it's at.
How do we find what we
know of human behavior,
we know of the evolving
media landscape,
what we know of culture
to connect with people
in a real meaningful way?
I think about my
job, ultimately,
is to translate
culture for brands.
And then translate brands
for the culture in such a way
that they connect in
real meaningful ways.
And luckily, I have
a chance do that
with some of the biggest
brands in the world, which
has been awesome.
Now, that's me.
But why does that
matter for you?
I'll tell you why
that matters for you.
Because culture allows us to
get much closer to humanity,
to connect with people in
a really meaningful way.
And what the literature is
showing us more and more,
the research is demonstrating,
that people care less
about the product
benefits, they care more
about emotional connections.
Our ability to
connect with humanity
matters more than
how sharp our razor
is, how long our battery
lasts, how much body
is in our shampoo.
People care about
human connections.
And it also drives the cash
register, which is pretty good.
But it should also matter
to you individually as well.
I'll tell you why.
You know, especially
for people who
are just starting
in their career
or are neophytes in their
career trying to figure it out,
we're constantly trying to
find a way to up our game.
What's our strategic
advantage at work
so I can rise up the ranks,
so I can be more successful?
And I would argue that
understanding culture
is a really powerful
way to do that.
Because I know you're
surprised, but I used
to get it in back in the day.
The boy, used-- to
I used to get it in.
I was a songwriter for a living.
I released music.
That's why did.
I used to perform.
I opened up for 112,
Jagged Edge, Keyshia Cole,
but like those
days are behind me.
I have a 3 and 1/2
year old, turning four,
turning 14 it seems like.
I and my wife and my daughter,
we live on a cul-de-sac.
And sometimes we
wear matching outfits
to get $4 off our sandwiches.
That's where we
are in life, right?
I got to work really,
really, really hard
to be a part of the culture.
But for a lot of
you, especially you
all who now about Kodak
and you did the thing
about "Bodak Yellow," a lot of
you are close to the culture.
And that becomes
your superpower.
That becomes your differentiator
as you think about your career.
How do you succeed in
the world of marketing?
You leverage culture.
Because brands who lead culture
are more successful than those
who follow.
You have that power
right now, especially
those who are close to it.
You know it, but
you're not using it.
It's like this guy.
You have all the tools
available to you,
but you're not using them.
If you're close to the
culture, stay close.
Stay close to the
culture and stay curious.
This will be the differentiator
that helps your brands succeed
by pushing, contributing
to the culture,
and pushing you forward.
Hope this was helpful.
Thanks so much, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I always tried to get
into your class at Ross,
but I never had enough bitcoins.
Great talk.
I'm curious if you can give
any examples of brands trying
to be the culture setter, but
then it ends up backfiring
and it's worse.
MARCUS COLLINS: I mean,
unfortunately, there
are more examples of that
than there are good examples.
I guess probably the most
ubiquitous one I can think of
is Pepsi trying to tap
into a cultural moment.
And they didn't make
it about people,
they made it about them.
And it turned into a meme
that was piled on their face.
Right?
And really, the issue there
is that those people at Pepsi,
they weren't dumb.
Really smart people people,
MBAs from great schools, right?
Smart people.
And it wasn't that they were
dumb or completely oblivious,
they just weren't
close to the culture.
They didn't understand the
shared beliefs, the artifacts,
the social norms, the
unwritten rules, the language
that they use.
And it's the lack of
understanding the nuances that
get you out of step.
If you don't
understand the nuances,
that's when you play yourself.
So the idea is to stay
very, very, very, very
close to the culture.
If oftentimes requires you
being a part of the culture as
opposed to being a tourist.
Back in the day we used to
call the ethnographic studies,
like getting way, way in.
AUDIENCE: Marcus, I think I
saw an example like a week ago
of something you're
talking about with Wendy's.
Did you see the tweet
that Wendy's sent out
where they were kind of
dogging the Nebraska coach?
His name is Frost.
And they said you have a frosty.
Michigan was beating
them by 40-0 at halftime.
And they put out a
tweet during halftime.
And next thing you
know, it's going viral.
I see it on the actual news.
I see it on ESPN and, you know--
and some Nebraska fans were
not happy because they said,
we eat at Wendy's too.
And Wendy's on their
official Twitter handle said,
we're pretty sure
that Nebraskans
have a sense of humor.
Some of them were still unhappy.
And they said, well, we may
start carrying pacifiers.
This goes crazy again.
Wow.
They're not talking about their
food, but then all of a sudden,
a lot of people are going I'm
going to go eat at Wendy's.
I just love that they've got
the courage to kind of get out
there and cause some trouble.
MARCUS COLLINS: Yeah,
I think Wendy's--
without being very, very
close to their business--
I think Wendy's figure they're
number three in this space?
Why not throw some shots?
And there entire
strategy at this point
is pretty much about
controlling everybody else.
It was control.
And you know what?
If feelings get hurt,
come on, laugh it off.
Considering this is a
part of their ethos now,
people don't-- maybe unless
you're from Nebraska--
people have pretty
thick skin when
it comes to that sort of thing.
But they are hugging all the
right nuances of the culture
they're a part of.
And we see things getting
shared or going viral,
because people who believe the
same thing that Wendy's does,
their take on things,
people will share it also.
Right?
It's all about community.
Community is another way of
talking about the cultures
that we're a part of.
AUDIENCE: You see a lot of
hype around like YouTube
collaborations,
Instagram collaborations,
these kind of integrations
that brands are trying to do.
I'd be curious to hear your
thoughts on that and whether
that's actually getting
close to culture
or if it's sort of counter.
MARCUS COLLINS: So are you
talking about like as far
as taking advantage of
a platform to do things?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Or more like the collaboration
with the creators
of those platforms.
MARCUS COLLINS: Right.
So I'd say this.
When we think about the
technology, the technology,
the zeros and ones, if you
will, the zeros and ones
are the facilitator of networks.
Right?
Things that would
normally be disparate
are now connecting things to
data that goes from one node
to the next.
So rules of the road,
same sort of thing.
And what we find when
we extrapolate that--
and I'm only talking about
the network of things,
the network of
people and things--
was once a network
of people and people.
And things like
Instagram, Facebook,
those social
networking platforms
are connecting people who
see the world similarly, who
are homophilically connected.
That is, they share the
same beliefs, social norms,
unwritten rules and rituals.
So then when brands partner
with platforms, technologies,
who understand the dynamics
of the network, dynamics
of the culture, they
borrow the proxy.
They borrow people who know
the culture better than they
do to get them closer to it.
That's massively powerful.
The idea, though, is
that it's always going
to be an outsource skills.
It's not in the
capability of the brand.
Capability is about
repeatability and reliability.
If I have to outsource
that, then I really
don't have it, which
is good, because they
get a couple at bats to
do something powerful.
But it's a challenge for
them, because it's not really
inside the ethos of what
the brand is all about.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
not a part of the culture
that you're trying
to get close to it,
you can run
ethnographic studies.
Are there tools that
are available to us?
I mean I'm actually thinking
of an advertising group
that I work with who
does aftermarket auto.
So it's exact opposite gender,
exact different age range,
different lifestyle entirely.
And I want to get to know them
a little bit more intimately.
So do have ideas for
tools we can tap into?
MARCUS COLLINS: I know one.
It's called Google.
[LAUGHTER]
The thing is this that--
which is why it's so
important to understand
the evolving media landscape--
social listening, search
behavior, viewership behavior.
We get a sense.
It's a proxy to what people
do, what they believe,
where they go.
They talk about
what they believe.
We know what they wear.
We know the artifacts
they don because there
are pictures of them.
These things provide a
proxy that we normally
would have to go live
with the coal miners
to know what coal miners do.
Instead, we can see
them from a distance
in a short sort of burst,
but a large representation
of the population that we
can pull a sample [INAUDIBLE]
and say this is a real thing.
Right?
And it's not really
defined by demography.
It's not defined by
psychographics either.
It's defined by
the beliefs that we
hold, the behaviors
we subscribe to,
and the language that we use.
In tech, like search,
like social listening,
those things
provide a bird's eye
view we normally
wouldn't have access
to without a ton of resources.
I rely on my--
my Excalibur of sorts is Google
Trends and Crimson Hexagon.
I use it for everything to
better understand people.
I have clients across
a wide spectrum
who are going after different
cultures, different networks.
It sort of requires me be able
to code switch between them.
And I can't do all that.
I can't be that
close to all of them.
So I can either
use people who work
at the agency who are
close to the culture or I
use some proxy via
technologies available.
AUDIENCE: With the
social listening tools,
I assume those are like
paid subscriptions.
So I'm more thinking we know
the wealth of Google tools
that we have at our
disposal, are there
free social listening tools?
MARCUS COLLINS: Absolutely.
Twitter Bandsearch.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
MARCUS COLLINS: Super free.
It's not as robust as using
Crimson or Google Suite
or something like
that, but it's free.
It gives you a nice down and
dirty look at what's going on.
Super representative
of a sample of people.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARCUS COLLINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My question is--
I know a lot of people have
seen like the Nike "Just Do It"
campaign, for example.
And so I guess my question
is when making a decision
to launch a campaign like that,
it might be considered-- well,
might not be considered,
some would consider
it to be culturally polarizing.
MARCUS COLLINS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How does
a company make--
what decision making
goes into that.
MARCUS COLLINS: So
I think it really
boils down to conviction.
What do you believe?
Simon Sinek would
say why do you exist?
People don't buy what you
did, they buy why you do it.
Right?
What do you believe?
And I think the biggest
opportunity for brands
are to tap into
networks who share
the same belief as the brand.
Because those are
the brands we use
to communicate this is who I
am, this is how I see the world.
And conviction by
its very essence
requires saying no to things.
It required doing
things that may
be divisive to people who don't
see the world the way you do.
And the fact that
Nike was like, no, we
stand with Kaepernick because
he aligns to our belief system.
And if you don't rock with that,
then you don't rock with us.
And those people who
were burning their Nikes
and saying I'm never going to
buy another pair Nike's, you're
going to die Nike,
your company sucks.
Well, the people
who believed what
Nike believes or would stand
with Kaepernick as well, what
did they say?
Give me two pair.
Right?
I want more.
I'm going to buy more,
because this thing is
a representation of our belief.
So it's difficult. It is a
simple idea, but it's not easy.
And we often confuse
simplicity and ease.
Like losing weight
is a simple idea.
Don't eat so much and move more.
Pretty simple.
And it ain't easy.
Right?
And the same thing goes
with convictions for brands.
What do you really believe?
If you believe that, will
you stand up for that
when everyone else
is sitting down?
When everyone else is against
you, will you stand up for it?
That is what conviction
is all about.
And the brands who have very
clear and salient convictions
not only do people know what
they believe and therefore they
use those brands, but all their
actions, their communications,
the people that they hire, those
people come towards the brand.
That's the idea that brands
should have the vision,
not just what they
communicate, but also
within the organization.
So that people who are a part of
the organization, they believe.
And they, too,
preach the gospel.
And they too are
demonstrably representations
of the brand's conviction.
AUDIENCE: What happens if a
company does have conviction
but then people start
doing it as appropriation?
MARCUS COLLINS: This is about
the nuances of the culture.
It's a hard one to say.
When we pay mind to the nuances,
we feel like it's a real thing.
If you don't know the
nuances, when someone
is saying they're just
appropriating, like,
no you don't understand.
Because the brand has
always been a part of this,
here are all the
demonstrative representations,
the evidence that shows this
brand's always been this way.
So them doing this
is nothing new.
It's just right in line with
what they've always been about.
But you got to be about it.
What did Diddy say?
Don't talk about, be about it.
Right?
Same thing.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
MARCUS COLLINS: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So I'm really big
on like influencer marketing.
So I've known in the past
sophomore year when Beyoncé
dropped to her little media
formation and she mentioned Red
Lobster.
And after that, like
sales increased.
And people were
going to Red Lobster.
And then just like last
week, Kylie Jenner,
she'd been on her Snapchat, she
had milk for the first time.
A lot of milk brands
were sending her milk.
And she's just like posting
like all these things.
So my question is is should
companies or brands continue
to ride that wave and use
that celebrity or influencer
to promote their brands?
Or should they try to
tap into other influencer
in other cultures?
MARCUS COLLINS: So
I'll start with this.
I'll answer your question
with a step back.
And then we'll step into it.
So first, is like unpacking
this idea of influencers.
So when we think of like the
Kylie Jenners, the Beyoncés,
the Kanyes of the
world as influencers.
And they have influence.
But the literature will
describe their influence
as ideological influence.
That is, we look up to that.
We aspire to that.
But we don't compare
ourselves to it.
Like we don't hear Kanye
West talking about wearing--
in his Bentley, and then
we get in our Toyota,
like I suck at life.
He has so much money, look at
our paycheck and I hate myself.
We don't do that.
We compare ourselves
to people who
are like us, people who are
part of the same network we
are a part of, our peers.
So when I think about
influencers at that level,
they're basically
contextualized media.
They're bright wattage media.
But their media isn't what
makes behaviors stick.
It's your people which
One would say that
culture moves forward
on the basis of one
simple question,
do people like me do
something like this.
If the answer is yes, I do it.
If the answer is no, I don't.
And we make that decision
hundreds of times a day.
People like me do
something like this.
So say, I see Jay-Z
wear a super cool hat.
I'm like that's dope.
I got shoes that match it.
I'm buying that hat.
Right?
I go buy the hat.
And I go to lunch
with my friends.
And sit at lunch and they're
like what are you wearing?
Like do you like my hat?
You look like an idiot,
take that hat off.
What am I going to do?
I'm taking that hat off.
And I put it in the closet.
It has never seen
the light of day.
Right?
Our people are what
makes the thing stick.
Because our people,
are the people
that we want to be connected to.
As Aristotle was saying, we're
social animals by nature,
so do everything
you can to connect
people who are just like us.
We ascribe to the same beliefs,
same social norms, same rules,
and we use the same language.
Right?
So I think about how we leverage
influence in this way, well,
we leverage the media that
they provide for sure.
Right?
But we have to make sure that
there is some concurrence.
That is, there's a lot
of visibility of people
like me doing that thing.
Right?
Like Beyoncé says, when he
does me good, I take his--
to Red Lobster.
Right?
And it wasn't till people
were me too, girl, homey,
you better take
me to Red Lobster.
Right?
That people like me do
this and there like,
yeah, I'm going to
do this as well.
And it creates the
cultural weight
that allows it to propagate
across the network.
So the short answer is,
yes, absolutely, as long
as it aligns to what
the brand is all about.
But what's most
important is how do we
get it to propagate
across the social web
to these networks of
people, these communities,
so that the behaviors stick?
There's a difference between
going viral and being
culturally contagious.
They didn't just spread person
to person and kind of peter
out.
But it spreads from
person to person
and takes hold of
the culture impacting
our beliefs, behaviors,
artifacts, and language.
Which we'll do in my
doctoral research.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARCUS COLLINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Marcus, you work with
some very respected brands.
I'm curious what is
your main criteria
before you decide to say yes
or no to a client or a project?
MARCUS COLLINS: So I
don't make the call.
Essentially, it's
the scope of work
that the agency
says is deemable.
But for me to work
on the projects,
there are things that
come into the building
that my teammates touch
that I don't touch.
And I'm fortunately, I'm
in a place in my career
where I can say, no, I'm not
going to touch those things.
I try to stay away--
I don't do any tobacco at all.
And I try to stay
away from alcohol,
particularly because
I don't consume it.
Right?
And I work with McDonald's
as one of my clients.
It was in the building.
While some may have issue
with McDonald's, I don't.
Right?
But I worked on Anheuser-Busch
for years, for four years,
and I've never tasted
the product at all.
And at that time,
I couldn't say no.
Where I was in my career,
Today, I'd say no thank you.
Just because it
doesn't subscribe--
it doesn't align to my beliefs.
It doesn't align to
what I like to do.
And me, it'd be hard for me to
sleep at night telling people
to consume more and consume
more and consume more.
Tobacco I'm completely against.
And therefore, I won't
even touch the stuff.
But again, it's just me.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about what you've done--
when you've been a part of the
brands and their competitor
has totally crushed it.
Like you're working
Miller and PBR sales
are completely skyrocketing.
Is the move usually to
ride on their success
or take the complete
opposite stance?
MARCUS COLLINS: I think it
depends on where the brand is.
So if you're the market leader,
and these guys are skyrocketing
up, you don't want
to put the spotlight
on those guys in most cases.
It's kind of like that's the--
that would be the
conventional wisdom.
I think about it like
remember when Drake and Pusha
T were beefing out this summer?
Right?
Drake is like here.
Pusha T is not as high
as far as the claim.
Pusha T throws jabs at Drake.
Drake responds.
And Pusha T's
record sales go up.
So a lot of times when
you're the market leader,
your job is just
to save the market.
Your job is to grow the
market, grow the category.
Someone throw shots at you
or someone's rising up,
just make sure that you keep
the category growing until they
become too close to call.
In those cases, you find
ways to lower that, sometimes
acquisition.
And then sometimes it's
finding ways to block them.
AUDIENCE: Have you been a
part of the brand strategy
that has successfully combating
a major spike in a competitor.
MARCUS COLLINS: I
would State Farm.
So State Farm, they are
the market leader by far.
But you see a lot of
market share being acquired
by, particularly, the GEICOs
of the world, Esurance,
Progressive, and Allstate.
So State Farm's like how do
you keep the category growing,
which the category is
sort of self moving,
because it's obligatory.
If you want to drive
in this country,
you need auto insurance.
Right?
But how do you get people to
get home owner's insurance
and get it with us?
Get financial services
and get it with us
while these other guys are
coming into the market?
So we found ways to use culture
to continue to boost the brand
and broaden the aperture
of the category,
particularly doing the Cliff
Paul campaign for State Farm.
Right?
So instead of talking
about how we're
better than All State, how
we're better than GEICO,
we just talked about how great
State Farm is at helping you.
With a magical agent "Like a
neighbor, State Farm is there,"
agent shows up.
Or personified what happens when
you have an agent with someone
like Cliff Paul.
Right?
Chris Paul.
All-Star State Farm--
All-Star point guard and
throws assists on the court.
Cliff Paul, All-Star
State Farm agent
throws an assists to real life.
All these things
to manifest what
the brand is all about so that
we can grow gross presence.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARCUS COLLINS: You got it.
AUDIENCE: So I'm kind of
interested in the brainstorming
and then zeroing in on what
we're going to do process.
I love the example of Potbelly's
that you just talked about.
And you're gathering data.
You're trying to understand
what the brand really
wants to go for, not just
sandwiches, but happiness.
But what does
brainstorming look like?
And then how do
you say, OK, this
is what we're going to go for.
Because sometimes I
watch a commercial,
I'm like I can't imagine
someone in a room being like,
OK, this what we're
going to go with.
So I was wondering what it looks
like to brainstorm and then
make that decision on, OK, what
we're going to move forward.
MARCUS COLLINS: So for me,
it's radical simplicity.
Just radical, radical,
radical simplicity.
So first question I ask is
why does the brand exist?
What do we believe is a brand?
How do we see the world?
Because the way we see
the world causes how
I'm going to behave the world.
So what do we believe?
And once you realize
what the why is,
what the conviction
of the brand is, now
we know who to target-- people
who see the world the way
we do.
Right?
So now we know who we are
and who we're going after.
The next question is what
do we want them to do?
Because marketing is
one of those words
that we use full of jargon
and abstractions, buzz words,
right?
Like what is marketing?
Asked 10 people, get
20 different answers.
So I think about
marketing as radically
simplistic as possible.
Oh, and the "Oxford
Dictionary" defines marketing
as going to market.
Marketing is going to market,
the market being people.
What is the core
function of marketing?
Get people to adopt behavior.
So we know what we're
all about as a brand.
We know who we're going after.
Now the question is what
do we want people to do?
And all the messages,
communications, campaigns,
products, activations,
they're all
designed to get people to move.
As simple as possible.
All the other things that we
build on it, the implications
and what not, we could
get into, but it all
starts with who
are we, who we're
going after, what behavior
we want them to take on.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
MARCUS COLLINS: My pleasure.
Thanks so much, guys.
[APPLAUSE]